la frontière troisième partie l'espace
frontalier
la référence bibliographique utilisée
pour préparer cet exposé le dictionnaire
de géographie des éditions hatier
la frontière l'insee par deux
territoires mais elle mène également à
la constitution d'un nouveau territoire
ce territoire frontalier s'étale de part
et d'autre de la limite il peut
constituer une zone déserte par exemple
la frontière entre l'afrique du sud
botswana pendant la période de
l'apartheid constituer un no man's land
de sécurité cette avance sur plusieurs
kilomètres de large il peut être aussi
sept espaces frontaliers être une zone
privilégiée de passage des changes
notamment lorsque les systèmes socio
économique en place dans les deux pays
sont différents
l'espace est alors un espace marché qui
tire parti de ces différences
l'exemple qui peut être pris ici est
celui de la frontière luxembourgeoise
cette zone peut même en arriver à
développer une dynamique totalement
différencier de la dynamique existante
dans les pays continuent dans ce cadre
elle peut même devenir une sorte de
région autonome temps est économiquement
que socialement voire politiquement
l'exemple des villes marché entre la
côte d'ivoire et le burkina faso
montre comment sont gérés de façon
indépendante certains territoires par
rapport au pouvoir et aux gouvernements
nationaux de ces deux pays
d'une façon générale toute frontière
induit un paysage est une pratique de
l'espace particulier dans la plupart des
cas la zone frontière est un espace à
l'écart du développement du pays une
marche ou un conte fin c'est à dire une
zone située à l'extrême limite du
territoire est considéré comme loin de
tours en témoigne la situation
géographique des capitales qui ne sont
que rarement situé à proximité des
frontières
le développement historique de l'état
s'est souvent fait à partir de ces
sièges de pouvoir d exception bien sûr
existe ici sur les cartes qui vous sont
proposés à l'écran vous voyez le cas de
la
l'union européenne où généralement les
zones les plus développés économiquement
donc celle en plus foncées sont situés
au centre ou en tout cas loin des
frontières du pays
par contre vous voyez que sur l'image de
droite dans certains pays d'afrique les
capitales et donc les régions les plus
développées à la fois politiquement
économiquement peuvent être continu
d'une frontière on a même le cas où deux
capitales sont vraiment situés de part
et d'autre de la frontière dans
république démocratique du congo et dans
la république du congo brazzaville
la zone frontière peut être évidemment
marginal mais elle peut aussi se
développer ou en tout cas évoluer dans
deux directions contradictoires opposé
dans le cas d'une frontière ouverte on
aura bien sûr l'apparition d'une zone
des changes dans le cas d'une frontière
fermée on aura l'apparition d'une zone
de contrôle qu'il débouchera elle même
sur un no man's land voyons ces deux cas
plus en détail
la frontière ouverte et d'abord une
frontière qui n'est pas contesté chaque
acteur spatiale reconnaît l'existence de
cette frontière et dans ce cas ci il n'y
a pas de compétition entre les états
séparés par cette frontière on verra
donc le développement des changes d'un
pays à l'autre par cette frontière il y
aura de forte migration d'individus qui
iront travailler généralement de la zone
la moins favorisés économiquement vers
la zone la plus favorisés économiquement
on voit bien ça ici
dans le sur la carte où la région
frontalière du luxembourg offre la
résidence à bon nombre de travailleurs
qui rompt le lendemain travailler au
luxembourg où les conditions sont à la
fois meilleures et où l'activité commune
économique est plus importante
il y aura bien sûr des besoins de
coordination entre les différentes
autorités qui devront ne fut-ce que dans
le domaine des transports prévoir des
mesures pour se mettre d'accord et pour
pouvoir valoriser ces échanges on aura
donc visuellement l'apparition de route
perpendiculaire à la frontière qui
permettront bien sûr aux individus et
aux marchandises de transiter par cette
frontière
comme pour la frontière ouverte la
frontière fermée n'est pas contestée au
niveau international ni par les acteurs
spatiaux par contre au lieu d'être le
lieu de coopération et des changes elle
est le lieu d'une tension et d'une
opposition
dans le cas d'une frontière fermée comme
l'ancien rideau de fer ou la frontière
actuelle entre les deux corée la zone
frontalière et du moins d'un côté une
zone sous haute surveillance militaire
ou policière et elle est coupée par de
nombreux postes de contrôle reliés entre
eux par des routes parallèles à la
frontière cette zone était nommé l'hymne
dans l' empire romain terme désignant le
chemin et par extension l'ensemble de la
frontière les nationaux sont
généralement exclues de cette bande et
constitue alors un véritable no man's
land
cette vidéo est ici terminé nous aurons
rendez-vous directement sur ce que j
pour le quizz n'oubliez pas les
questions que vous pourriez poser en
classe et je vous souhaite une bonne fin
de journée